moving on now where he may learn more
today about the mysterious killing a
former Arkansas state Senate state
senator Linda Colin Smith
Rebecca O'Donnell pictured in blue on
the right is suspected in the case she
is expected to appear in court sometime
today Colin Smith pictured on the left
was found dead outside her home earlier
this month a former member of her staff
says the two women were friends CTM
national correspondent dareka Duncan is
in Walnut Ridge Arkansas outside the
jail where Donnell is being held
Sarika house the victim's family
responding well they're just devastated
Adrianna as you can imagine in fact the
family of the former state senator
issued a statement saying we are
sickened and upset that someone so close
to Linda would be involved in such a
heartless crime now even though
O'Donnell has not been formally charged
with anything State Police say that her
arrest signals a major turning point in
this case without this the Sheriff's
Office couldn't accomplish what we have
10 days after Arkansas police discovered
the body of former state senator Linda
Colin Smith sheriff's deputies moved in
and arrested 48 year old Rebecca
O'Donnell the investigation is presently
at a critical juncture investigators say
Collins was found dead on June 4th
outside her home around 2 hours
northeast of Little Rock her body was
reportedly found wrapped in a blanket a
day or two after neighbors say they
heard gunshots stuff like this doesn't
happen here everybody loved her the 57
year old mother and grandmother was
elected to the state Senate as a
Republican in 2014 I need your vote but
lost re-election last year's Linda is
one of those people that couldn't be
bought uncorruptible that wanted to tell
people that bad stuff was happening at
the Capitol ken yang was Collinses
communication director he says O'Donnell
worked on Collins's reelection campaign
they're good friends they traveled
together than did grassroots stuff even
after Linda lost re-election but the
connection between the two women appears
to go deeper court records posted online
show Donald served as a witness for
Collins during her recent divorce from a
retired circuit
one local newspaper described the
separation as a bitter legal fight over
money and property her passing has left
a great void in our state our party in
our hearts at memorials last week
those who knew Collins remembered her as
a trusted colleague and friend Brian
King served alongside Collins in the
state Senate we were able to start with
her and know her as a person as a mother
and as somebody that really cared about
issues she was courageous and undaunted
investigators have released few details
about Collins's death and the day after
police found her body a judge sealed all
the documents related to that case as
for Rebecca
O'Donnell's family they have no comment
at this time Tony